what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the latest mind-blowing
twists and turns in the boku no hero
story including the huge hero attack
doctor Yuji COEs epic troll and the
sheer awesomeness of the glorious bunny
Queen herself the number 5 pro hero
miracle several major boku no hero
theories about quirks and nomu have just
been confirmed and this current arc is
shaping up to be one of the best ever
there is a lot to talk about
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content right here on the
channel and you want us to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know and
in case you're new to the channel please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications a big thank you to all of
our anime our pro patrons who make
videos like this one possible YouTube is
getting more unreliable by the day and
our patrons really help us keep the
content going for example thanks to our
patrons we're now able to pay editors to
help us put out more videos including my
boy kore who is the editor for this
video definitely check cor out he makes
quality anime content link in the
description I'll talk more about patreon
at the end of the video but until then
please be warned that this video will
contain MHA manga spoilers we are
dealing with the latest developments in
the boku no hero stories so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned the action picks up right where
the last chapter left off with the
massive hero operation aimed at taking
out two villain strongholds at the same
time jakku hospital and a paranormal
Liberation Front mansion two locations
which are approximately 80 kilometers
apart at the hospital after being
confronted by endeavour and the other
heroes the doctor Fujiko attempts to run
away but he is brought down by eyes
awaaz cloth tentacles
however as the doctor falls and as iowa
uses his quirk to erase the doctors
quirk the doctor appears to age very
rapidly until he suddenly looks much
much older than he used to endeavor an
ice ax will conclude that the quirk
database must be wrong Fujiko must have
been using some type of quirk after all
and
quark was making him younger this means
that you gqo is actually a lot older
than he appears to be and this also
means that he has been around and doing
his thing in the shadows for a very long
time sooo kouchi says that this same
quark that the doctor was using may be
the key behind all for one's longevity
as we know all-4-one has been alive for
many generations and for a long time the
heroes have suspected that the reason he
was able to live for so long was that he
has some sort of extremely rare
longevity quark it appears that both the
doctor and all-4-one have been using
this same rare quark although it is
unknown whether this quark was stolen
from someone else or whether it was
manufactured by the doctor himself this
is a major revelation this means that
the doctor could have an entirely
different origin story than we could
have possibly imagined
because we had assumed that he was much
younger if he has lived for generations
it is possible that you giucose original
identity was someone else entirely
and it is possible that he has been with
all-4-one since the very beginning also
since it would have been highly
suspicious if people close to you G Co
realized that he wasn't ageing normally
it is quite possible that this
Fujiko assumed many different identities
over the past several generations and so
this doctor identity may just be his
latest one after this huge new piece of
information I am very curious to learn
the true origins of OG Co who was he
originally how did he meet all-4-one and
what was he doing before he assumed his
current identity as a medical expert and
philanthropist present Mike then grabs
the fragile aged Fujiko and demands to
know why the doctor is using such an
incredible power for evil if you G Co
discovered a way to make people aged
slower and live longer he could use that
discovery to do so much good in the
world
he could become a medical hero and a
living legend but instead he chose to
use his power to help villains and
conduct human experiments this is a
great point and it makes me even more
curious to find out more about ug hos
origins some of the employees at the
hospital try to jump to the doctors
defense and they ask the heroes to back
down but endeavour
tell them to step back soon every
civilian is evacuated from the hospital
as the heroes are preparing for a deadly
fight against the nomu and as we shall
see they're not wrong then we see
noobest girl and top tier waifu miracle
using her incredible rabbit-like speed
and agility to infiltrate the morgue the
only place in the hospital from which
the secret section is accessible
Fujiko calls out for the heroes to
release him but that word release seems
to be the command that all the normal
were waiting for in order to activate
dozens of nomu suddenly start moving
within the hospital everything from
regular nomu to massive beast like black
Noma who are of course the more powerful
normal variety in fact all the Nome will
suddenly break through the hospital
walls and ceiling and as endeavor Aizawa
and present Mike brace for impact
Fujiko is pierced by one of the Nomos
drills
Fujiko laughs as he reveals that he was
just one of twice's clones and he then
simply dissolves into that strange mud
like substance that all twice as clones
turn into once they have sustained a
significant amount of damage if you've
seen my video on the previous chapter
then you know that I said that I believe
that the villains have more tricks up
their sleeve I simply did not believe
that this hero operation would go so
smoothly and that the doctor would allow
himself to be captured sold easily to be
honest I did not think of the
possibility that the doctor could
actually be a twice clone but I remember
that a few guys down in the comments on
my video suggested that very option so
great job guys you were right
you called it we are then taken into the
secret section of the hospital where the
real doctor presumably the real doctor
is preoccupied with Shiga Rocky's
procedure
Fujiko considers shigaraki to be his
masterpiece so we can assume that she
got Rocky's new form is going to be more
powerful than any of the know mood that
would you co-created so far which is in
itself an amazing and terrifying concept
it is then revealed that ug Co has
indeed been copying quirks and then
collecting them in little jars here at
the hospital
back when the high-end nomu named hood
first appeared like a year and a half
ago i theorize that ichigo had cloned
musculars quark and then given it to her
and it turns out that this theory about
cloning or copying quirks was indeed
correct this is important because it
means that you G Co doesn't need to use
all four want to actually steal a quirk
in order to use it he can just copy the
quirk which allows the original user to
keep using it while also allowing pooja
code to give that same quirk to various
no move if he chooses the seemingly real
doctor is thinking about how he doesn't
want to abandon this hospital because of
all the hard work that is here the
copied quirks the various high-end nomu
all of the long hours that he put in
with all for one it is all here however
the doctor doesn't have much of a choice
because the incredible miracle
effortlessly destroys dozens of regular
normal as she advances on the doctors
secret lair Fujiko realizes that someone
is coming and he attempts to get the
little normal Johnny to teleport him and
shigaraki away from the hospital but
before you g co can reach Johnny miracle
bursts through the wall
smashing the jarred quirks in the
process and she also crushes poor Johnny
under the rubble damn I kind of like
that little guy the chapter ends as a
fierce and stunning miracle asks ug Co
if he is the real deal
and you chica screams and I can only
assume also pees his pants in this
moment
first of all Wow miracle Wow
we knew that she was the number 5 pro
hero but until now I did not realize
that she was also in the top 5 waifu's
in boku no hero not only is she
beautiful but she is incredibly badass
and as spike Spiegel says I love a woman
that can kick my ass ok back to the
story and the true implications of what
just happened this chapter ends very
similarly to the previous chapter with
the doctor or at least whom we believed
to be the doctor scared out of his mind
as a top-tier pro hero confronts him
face to face but in this chapter we saw
that the ug co from upstairs in the
hospital was a clone so could it be
possible that this other huge eco is
also a clone well the fact that you G Co
thought to use a clone in the first
place suggests that he was expecting
that something was about to happen back
in chapter 2 57 it was
revealed that the doctors public
appearances at the hospital were rare
one of the nurses was actually surprised
to see him so it's not like Gucci Co has
been regularly using this clone to make
the hospital staff think that he is
doing legitimate medical work while he's
actually downstairs experimenting on
shigaraki since his appearances are rare
we know that he doesn't use clones on a
regular basis so then the question is
why use a clone
now why today like I said in my previous
videos it is possible that the villains
knew that something was coming because
they suspected hawks of being a spy it's
also possible that the Oberoi Hospital
hint was not accidental but rather a
deliberate clue given to the heroes by
the villains in order to lure them into
a trap so is it possible that this
second ug Co is also a clone and that
the hero trap has only been deepening as
they advance further into the hospital
there are some factors that seem to go
against this interpretation including
the fact that who Chico secret lab was
just trashed his quirk jars broken
johnny was crushed and even his
masterpiece shigaraki is now in danger
as he appears to be defenseless inside
one of the tubes surely the doctor
wouldn't willingly put his entire life's
work in danger if he could avoid it so
if he was really setting a trap he could
have done it literally anywhere else but
again if the doctor didn't see anything
coming why was the clone used on this
specific day could it be that the second
ug Co is also a clone and that even
shigaraki inside the tube is a fake as
well twice can only create up to two
clones at a time but now that he is able
to clone himself again his clones can
also create two clones each so having
more than two clones inside the hospital
is absolutely possible I know I feel
like I'm turning into twice here I don't
know who is real and who was a clone
anymore and now I'm thinking that
everyone could be a clone even poor
little Johnny it could be that all of
this is a really elaborate trap
orchestrated by the villains or it could
be that the villains didn't see this
coming but perhaps she kuraki has
already gotten strong enough to wreck
the heroes even if he doesn't finish the
entire procedure so even if the lab is
destroyed and she gerak his power up his
halted he might still be able to emerge
from the tube and ruin the heroes day
and of course we still haven't seen
assault on the paranormal Liberation
Front mansion so who knows what will
happen there one thing is for sure I'm
absolutely loving this current war arc
in boku no hero and I think it's just
going to keep getting better and better
seriously this has been thrilling and
full of unexpected twists and miracle is
an absolute bunny queen I'm actually
thinking of starting an official musical
fan club or something hit me up on
Twitter at anime uproar if you want to
join my musical rabbit cult oh and they
better not kill me to cool off or
something like that now that she's alone
in the doctor's lab I would be extremely
pissed if that happens also I am still
expecting an all for one Prison Break to
occur at some point during this war arc
my initial thinking was that this entire
operation could be a trap designed by
the villains to lure the heroes
attention away from Tartarus prison
I've actually been saying for years that
all-4-one is planning a prison break and
that he is going to use kudo kitties
quirk ragdolls quirk and a bunch of
other quirks to escape from Tartarus I'm
not sure if this will happen now or
later on but I'm still fully expecting
it to happen overall we learned a lot of
very interesting information in this
chapter we learned that Fujiko is
actually a lot older than he appears and
that he is using a quirk that appears to
make him younger who knows who this guy
really was before he adopted the public
persona of a doctor and philanthropist
but I'm very interested in learning more
about him we also got confirmation that
yes
Fujiko and all-4-one are able to copy
quirks and store them while still
allowing the original user to keep using
the quirk this means that theoretically
Fujiko and all-4-one may have every
villains quirk at their disposal and
have just been waiting to infuse the hi
and no move with all these insane clerks
there are just so many options and
possibilities with that idea alone I
really want the next chapters to come
sooner like right now finally you might
have heard that the creator of MHA
Kouhei horikoshi received criticism for
his choice of name for juco his real
name or alleged real name which appeared
in the previous chapter the criticism
came from the fact that one of the words
used could be interpreted as a reference
to Japanese war crimes during World War
two an issue that is still very
sensitive in China and Korea in
particular
horikoshi apologized for this and he
said that he would change
name going forward he also said that the
similarity was purely coincidental he
was using the word as a reference to a
Chico's physical appearance not to World
War two and from what I know about
Japanese I do believe that certain words
can have multiple meanings depending on
the context obviously I don't know
horikoshi personally and I can't read
his mind but I definitely don't think
that he would deliberately try to offend
people in China Korea or anywhere else
horikoshi knows how popular boku no hero
has become worldwide and there is no
incentive for him to alienate his
Chinese and Korean fans on purpose
it's not like horikoshi is some kind of
Japanese imperialist if anything boku no
hero is a series that relies a lot more
on Western culture and Western hero
tropes than most anime and manga if what
of course she really was some sort of
Japanese cultural imperialist then why
would he rely so heavily on Western
culture and Western sources instead of
focusing entirely on Japan's rich
cultural heritage it just doesn't make
sense to me and I definitely give
horikoshi the benefit of the doubt on
this one and with that said please let
me know what you thought about these
latest developments in the story is the
real logical in real trouble
or are things again not quite as they
seem did the heroes really get one over
on the villains or were the villains
expecting the heroes all along please
share your takes down in the comments
below if you enjoyed this video you want
to see more videos like it please leave
a like to let me know and if you happen
to be new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
about to turn on all notifications
please follow me on Twitter and or
Instagram at anime uproar if you want to
join my miracle fan club I want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who support our content
and make these videos possible first up
let me thank our the one tier patrons
the ones who rise above all other clans
including Ingrid ah a Lola nod of
makoto-kun the world Steelers the school
bus and Tyson query know I also can't
forget our awesome pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
dress very dolla beat alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt's ki on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP Roja
Kippur Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku
Timothy II vodkas Jean d'Arc and Joe
Stanton if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our page and exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us spanks Cowboys
[Music]